la la la la plupart des gens je suis
désolé de généraliser mais la la la la
la la plupart des gens confondent un
pommier avec un homme ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que le pommier lui
n'engendre que des pommes n'est ce pas
mais pourquoi condamné l'homme à nant
gendrey qu'un seul fruit
ce que je veux dire c'est que lorsque je
dis deux mois pour tenter d'effacer qui
je ne suis pas n'est ce pas lorsque je
nie compositeur clarinettiste et c'est
isp aux attentes de cette tout ce que
vous voudrez parfois tout ça est balayée
d'un revers de la main et les gens
disent barak et lyons tuer ce qu'on
appelle un touche à tout et il y à là
dedans très souvent comment dirais-je
beaucoup de mépris
autrement dit on dit voilà un homme
incapables de canaliser à la fois son
apprentissage son désir d'oeuvrer sa vie
d'homme dans une direction droite nettes
précises et voilà simplement un homme
qui croit qu'il est capable à la fois de
composés de jouer de la mémé mais pour
qui se prend il
eh bien écoutez je ne me prends pas pour
un pommier
je crois que les oeuvres n'est ce pas
sont des faits des gestes mais au delà
de ça ce sont des débordements et quand
je veux dire débordements c'est qu'il y
à toujours dans l'oeuvre qui sort de
vous n'est ce pas une fois qu'elle est
là une fois qu'elle existe un regard à
jeter sur elle comme si ce que vous
veniez de créer était encore quelque
chose à apprivoiser
autrement dit en général j'ai le
sentiment souvent reconduit et répété
qu'une oeuvre réussie c'est au départ
une oeuvre qui vous déplaît donc
peut-être et je m'en voudrais d'être
scolaire en faisant un exposé basée sur
la notion de liberté
peut-être que la première des libertés
c'est celle de ceux déplaire en tout cas
je dirais six là où c'est à dire tout à
fait passionnant c'est que souvent
pendant que les gens me voient habillée
comme ça vous voyez alors moi je porte
le costume de mariage de mon grand père
qui s'est marié en 1944 mais je le porte
pas simplement parce que je me trouve
beau avec parce qu'il ya des tas de gens
qui me trouve parfaitement clownesque
n'est ce pas bien qu'en fait je attendez
attendez je vais prendre une ligne
pertes en fait comme en direct ne vous
étonnez pas si je fais quelques sorties
de route dans mon raisonnement n'est ce
pas tout simplement parce que je ne je
crois en fait que l'intelligence est
faite de toutes les sorties de route et
de tous les appels possibles
je ne crois pas en la pensée en ligne
droite je ne crois pas ni aux
professeurs ni aux bons élèves
d'ailleurs une sortie de route dans la
sortie de route en général un mauvais
professeurs et un bon élève sont
toujours convaincus d exactement la même
chose
ils vous disent au départ mon enfant
admettons que je me mette dans la peau
du professeur n'est ce pas au départ mon
enfant tu bâtis le cadre rien n'est plus
important que le cadre et une fois que
tu as déterminer par exemple dans le cas
d'une rédaction
l'introduction la thèse et l'antithèse
en fait toutes ces conneries n'est ce
pas une fois que tu as bâti sa à
l'intérieur ah bah oui
or à l'intérieur sans toi libre non mais
ça non mais ça mais mais mais ça mais
mais mais mais mais mais mais sam
mais mais mais mais mais c'est une
connerie monumentale
ce que je veux dire c'est que c'est
exactement le chemin inverse qu'il faut
emprunter
il faut d'abord assumée et aller vers la
liberté totale et cette liberté totale
naturellement va convoquer un cadre qui
sera le vôtre
et c'est dans ce cadre là que vous aurez
pu vous développer ce que je veux dire
c'est que la parole juste mon cher mais
cher mais cher mais cher la parole juste
la pensée juste l'oeuvre juste le geste
juste
c'est quelqu'un qui a su outre passé
l'outrance c'est impossible de maîtriser
c'est impossible de maîtriser en
espérant obtenir la maîtrise au départ
il faut tout lâcher les enfants au
départ il faut tout lâcher
et une fois que vous savez jusqu'où on
peut aller trop loin
eh bien vous naturellement vous fait un
petit pas derrière et puis vous dites
non c'était quand même mieux comme ça
alors c'est à dire tu peux avoir l'air
ridicule ça aussi alors à la une alors
ouais bon pourquoi je porte ce costume
enfin je voudrais pas noyer tout ça dans
une espèce de symbolique qui voit là je
ne voudrais pas vous expliquer qu'en
fait quand je porte ce costume
quand je porte ce costume en fait j'ai
l'impression d'avoir sur moi le poids du
passé
enfin de l'inscrire dans le présent et
de lui offrir un futur et ça je trouve
que me situer au milieu de ça c'est à
dire avoir autant d'horizon derrière moi
que d'horizon devant moi je trouve que
c'est le plus beau cadeau qu'on peut se
faire un espace
j'ai pas vraiment peur des silences j'ai
pas vraiment peur des silences parce que
vous savez c'est curieux les lélés les
gens regardent vos silences avec une
espèce d'affolement qu'ils emplissent de
toutes leurs angoisses comme r10 et plus
qui dit il a perdu son texte annonce est
terrible parce qu'il sait pas ce qu'il
dit en fait mais ce type là improvise
non chérie tu verras il connaît tous par
coeur il fait semblant de la promise et
mais tout ça est une machine huilée
fantastiquement je dois vous avouer
malheureusement pourquoi malheureusement
je dois vous avouer que non en fait je
je je je je je je je ne comprends pas
l'intérêt de préparer la parole
autrement que dans l'affolement d'une
première phrase à dire tout se passe
tout se joue au moment où vous arrivez
et vous avez une 1ère phrase à prononcer
et c'est cette première phrase l'énergie
que vous mettez là dedans qui comment
dirais-je survolera dans vos poumons
tout le reste noté et de toute façon
dans 5 minutes vous ne saurez même plus
pourquoi vous êtes là en train de
m'écouter et moi pourquoi je suis là en
train de parler comme tous les débuts
sont impossibles
il n'y a rien de plus fuyant qu'un début
essayez de mettre la main sur un début
essayez de mettre la main sur une
première phrase essayer de savoir
pourquoi je suis là
qui faut-il remercier acquis même pas
moi qui faut-il remercier plus je
cherche le début de toute chose
plus je me rends compte qu'un début en
contrarie un autre écart début contrarie
le début qui a été contrariée par un
autre et que l'autre début contrarie le
début qui a été contrariée par un autre
début lui-même contrarier ce que je veux
dire c'est que c'est la spirale
infernale
alors
j'ai étudié au conservatoire la musique
comme comme il se doit et j'étais comme
il se doit renvoyer du conservatoire ce
que vous prenez dans un premier dans un
premier temps comme une espèce de deux
gifles et beaucoup plus que ça et bien
au-delà de la jfp qu'on veut vous donner
en général le renvoi doit être vécue et
sera fait qu et sera oui si vous êtes
toujours comme une bénédiction
je ne pourrai jamais remercier mon
médiocre professeurs du conservatoire de
nice d'avoir eu la perversité si bien
appuyé de dect est de détecter en face
de lui l'élève qui avait du génie et
c'est dire non c'est pas possible je
veux penser à ce gamin là ce que je veux
dire c'est qu'en tant que gamin je
n'étais pas techniquement meilleur que
lui
mais vous savez
il y a des gens qui sont allergiques à
l'incandescence et certains professeurs
quand ils vous jugent mal c'est qu'ils
vous ont très très bien jaugé voilà pour
l'éducation nationale dans son ensemble
je ne comptais me réconcilier avec
personne je vois qu'au fond s'installe
en faisant le moins de bruit possible
mais il n'y a rien de plus bruyants que
les gens qui tentent d'être discret
parce que finalement on est captée apps
voilà on est on est captée par leur
discrétion et il n'ya rien vous avez de
plus mais on dit bon ils sont discrets
qu'est ce que je fais et vous êtes
attraper comme une espèce d'électricité
mental qui court entre vous et moi
n'est ce pas par cette espèce dans vie
de ne pas faire de bruit et ça se
termine toujours par une catastrophe
bon
oui
il faut arrêter de penser verticalement
toute une partie de notre notamment
écriture musicale mais je voudrais pas
parler musique avec trop de précision
technique mais une grande partie de
notre pensée et construite de façon
monumental un peu comme les vous savez
ce qu'on appelle les cathédrales c'est
espèce de truc généralement
insupportable grandiloquent et qu'on est
obligé de trouver beau parce qu'ils ont
mis cinq siècles à nous bâtir si ces
trucs horribles a alors on rentre on dit
robin oui c'est beau mais c'est pas que
c'est beau c'est que ça nous tombe
dessus vous comprenez ce que je veux
dire c'est pas que ces mots c'est que
qui a le courage devant notre-dame de
dire [ __ ] c'est moche alors je veux
dire qu'un certain degré de
monumentalité un certain degré
d'accumulation d'argent un certain degré
d'accumulation de durée et de pouvoir
que sais-je votre possibilité de juger
le fait est complètement balayées c'est
pour ça aujourd'hui c'est toujours très
intéressant d'aller voir les gens dans
une galerie d'art ou dans un musée voir
je ne sais pas moi jeff koons paris dont
vous connaissez cette artiste et les
gens sont là alors il se trimballe à à
pompidou devant des photos pornos avec
des phallus d'un mètre cinquante comme
ça et tout bon et puis bon alors ils
sont là vous avez comme des poules
devant un mégot fin et alors bon
intérieurement j'ai rien contre jeff
koons et j'ai rien contre les phallus
d'un mètre cinquante je veux dire bon
mais intérieurement
ils se disent ah le haut le haut le
convoyer à le nul en arrive à ça c'est
de la mettez vous leur dites j'ai ça
vaut dix millions d'euros
voilà comment le jugement est aboli à
force de vous piétinez la tête c'est
pour ça
que je privilégie toujours la pensée
horizon horizontal et permettez-moi de
vous décrire
à ce titre-là la parole d'un critique
d'art qui disait à un jour non je vais
même pas le dire parce qu'ils méritent
même pas d'être oubliée donc je vais
changer de sujet
il me semble que la poésie c'est la
juste distance entre ce que sont les
mots et ce que nous savons des mots nous
avons vis-à-vis du langage notamment au
moment de l'écriture poétique mais je
veux dire que ça doit être pareil avec
tout le monde nous avons des appétits
d'un pesanteurs qui fait qu'à un moment
c'était l'heure précise où à ma droite
il fallait l'enlever une poubelle ça
c'est extraordinaire c'est à dire que là
vous voyez j'étais en train de me
connecter avec la pensée précise
poétique la plus comment dirais-je
comment dirais-je la plus la plus la
plus la plus la plus la plus la plus la
plus la plus la pub la plus et vous
voyez que les mots manquent
voyez les les moments qu'on sait pas que
les moments petit con on demande
beaucoup trop aux mots les mots ne
peuvent pas supporter tout ce qu'on veut
leur faire dire et tout ce qu'on veut
leur faire porter en bref je veux dire
que là j'étais en train de parler et qui
a un type qui vient d'enlever une
poubelle c'est quand même extraordinaire
c'est quand même extraordinaire et
pourtant ça se passe c'est à dire qu'en
même temps on peut être pensé être un
homme d'altitude et est rattrapé par le
premier mec qui vous ramasse une
poubelle sur votre droite
savait il m'est arrivé une fois un jour
l'une des expériences mystiques les plus
sublimes de mon existence
jallet sur un plateau de télévision
habillé avec une élégance mais ne pas
papa clownesque comme aujourd'hui mais
vous voyez enfin vraiment je vous avais
même alors mais alors mais alors le mais
alors mai mais alors jeu mais j'avais
tout plaquer chez kenzo j'étais sublime
et je vais pour prendre un taxi et à ce
moment précis à ce moment précis un
pigeons survolant le ciel de notre
capitale se décide à me donner une leçon
extraordinaire
le pigeon me chie sur le crâne quand je
vous dis que le pigeon me chie sur le
crâne je parle de ça m'est cher avec une
précision chirurgicale
à tel point qu'il n'y avait pas une
goutte de fientes sur mon costume mon
costume était sublime
je veux dire que vraiment vraiment et ma
tête était dans un état
j'ai sauvé la situation en appelant de
toute urgence un ami qui habitait à ce
moment là dans le combat il faut que je
vienne me faire un shampoing quoique je
te raconterai plus tard il faut que je
m'en base non mais non mais non non non
non non non mais là vous vous rendez
compte
il a suffi d'une fientes de pigeons pour
me faire passer du sublime au ridicule
et au fin fond du ridicule
retrouvez le sublime et là je me suis
dit waouh
je n'ai jamais retrouvé ce pigeon
[Applaudissements]